I like to know my audience who here is
not CS do we have double e's do we have
MBA folks w know anyone okay great so
like I've had a handful double e's okay
right so we won't talk only about the
soccer we'll talk about the hardware as
well we're gonna cover everything anyway
but I want to skip the hardware part
let's see any business folks even if
your background is w or or CS okay okay
okay great
my business cards are here you can grab
them afterwards I have some props you
will get to them I have a lot more
material than can cover in an hour just
I'm always ready for any questions that
I can I can jump around you all know
what equality does we we do I mean it's
really hard to not know what quantity
does these days Rome's in the news every
every day we've been getting almost
every award you know top 10 start up top
10 this and top 2 this and which is
great but that comes with lots of hard
work and resulting business activity
which is also great
but that comes with very little sleep
which is okay so we make lidar we are
famous for our core technology which is
the solid state lidar having said that
the software behind the solid state
light are is where the brains are and
ultimately the we have multiple layers
of application and perception smart
perception software and then scenario
analysis decision-making and so on all
of these layers are laid on top of the
basic point cloud that you got out of a
3d lidar sensor
we'll talk about all this and then
there's the data you collect with the
big the big shovel that we use to to
fill the dump truck that the cloud is
and get things processed and fused
between different sensors not not just
for light are will talk about fusion
between lidar and video and radar and so
on the company is three and a half years
old but in terms of introduction I
worked on the core chip that is the core
of the solid state lidar 25 years ago
for my PhD it was sponsored by DARPA it
was the biggest chunk of my PhD at
Columbia then I went on to get business
degrees from in this order the Harvard
MIT and Stanford this is my fourth start
up all my startups are based on the
hardware part of them is always silicon
photonics I've built and sold three
companies to our telecom companies one
is a solar company and now this is laser
sensing but that's really that's exactly
what I worked on for my PhD and so with
that so to avoid too much suspense and
people wondering what the product looks
like let's just show it to you right now
that's the solid state lidar you know
you compare it with what we commonly
called it the KFC bucket on the Google
car this is a smaller lighter lower
power consumption completely solid-state
macro-level micro-level so this is this
does not have mark remembers mirrors
that the naked eye does not see no
nothing moves through a solid state
based on optical phased array beam
interferences like it's an optical
version of the phased array radar and
now this you never see it on a vehicle
so it's not only small it's also hidden
it's always behind behind
inside the side view mirrors
in the bumper behind the grill and so
the the car that has this basically
looking look like looks like it has
nothing and that's the point this is the
kind of car you want to buy you're not
gonna buy a car that looks like it has
the lab bench on top it's it's cool for
pilots and yeah yeah yeah but don't you
buy a luxury vehicle you don't want it
to have a bunch of instruments on top so
our mission basically is just to do five
things that's all we do we save lives
energy space time and money and so it's
saving lives is safety and then the
other four are efficiency so we are
energy efficient space efficient time
efficient and cost efficient our
solutions my background in the industry
I'm gonna just flash this I'm not gonna
spend too much time on this just so you
see the companies I worked with and sold
and I say stay with the parent company
for many years actually typically which
is not common for for for entrepreneurs
and then we and we did some acquisitions
over time long story short I started
after my PhD at allied signal in
Morristown New Jersey we became
Honeywell after we acquired Honeywell
started three companies sold them sold
one company to Corning want to DuPont
want to ask energy in Korea became the
CTO of SunEdison and then now quality
for what we are about disruption through
innovation and through business model
innovation technical and business model
innovation we disrupt the transportation
space as well as security industrial
automation mapping digital navigation as
well as location-based services
and mapping we are mapping the world
making a unit like this this Allstate
lidar for a couple making it available
for a couple of hundred bucks meaning
our costs you can guess is about half of
that allows you to go in every vehicle
now it's no longer the $80,000 unit that
you see on
the typical Google car wheel of Google
by the way not not trying to say
anything bad about Google it's just I
mean they use it to develop software
right so whatever works to develop
software that's fine so but in that case
when it's a mechanical lidar and you're
using it for development to develop
software
if it breaks okay you go back to the
shop you replace it but when you're
using it to actually enable an
autonomous vehicle and you're taking a
nap it's not as cool when it breaks it
has to be solid state and that's not
just our opinion because we have this we
have this because that's what the
customer said you know location-based
services ultimately you can imagine a
smart IOT Internet of Things where each
thing doesn't just tell you where it is
it shows you everything that's going on
around it and that's a very smart IOT so
business model basically yes we do have
core hardware technology we have a lot
more software than Hardware multiple
layers that I describe and ultimately we
will get into data services and that's
our ecosystem we have the core hardware
the the data processing on board that
controls the systems that control the
vehicle and we build maps using that
data we have we communicate in real in
real time using a solid cellular
connection observations and observation
can be any object around you a
pedestrian vehicle debris pothole etc it
can be a traffic condition weather
condition accident so on all of that
gets communicated immediately via a
cellular connection on average a car
driving in moderate traffic it collects
about 25 observations per minute each
one takes only one kilobyte to
communicate type location driving
a couple of hours a day five five five
days a week that's really just fifty
megabytes per month so it's not that
bandwidth hungry so any very basic data
plan can can can handle that then you
need the Wi-Fi connection to upload to
the cloud a the base map you collecting
observations communicating those in real
time to everybody else who has a system
like yours
so they are aware of what's going on
then the base map with it where we are
building in the cloud a global
centimeter accurate daily updated colors
colored point cloud map that is
certainly a lot more data intensive if
you drive eight hours a day five days a
week in one week you'll collect about a
terabyte of data so you definitely need
for a couple for a couple of hundred
gigs per day you need a Wi-Fi connection
every vehicle has it has it has a Wi-Fi
connection at some point even so for
poor a personal vehicle that's easy
right there and you're gonna park your
car in a garage at some point even a UPS
truck that's driving most of the time at
some point is going to go to a loading
dock to get loaded and it's gonna be
waiting there for a couple hours that's
enough to upload all the data it
collected and it downloads refreshes
Delta's based on what everybody else has
collected for the area of interest so in
our case say the Bay Area so an IOT Road
map would look something like this it
started in the early day and our own
RFID used to be a concern we considered
something there you stick on something
and now okay everything is tagged and
you have you have an IOT these days is
much much smarter it's you have
you have sensors that detect classify
attract objects you have the ability to
crunch onboard that that data to make
decisions using data fusion between
different sensor types lidar camera and
radar so and if you're doing that in the
context of deep learning now you need an
advanced processor we need a GPU we are
working very closely with NVIDIA we also
work with freescale and others on the
other CUDA development so a new paradigm
in 3d sensing involves basically
disruptive hardware technologies 3d
sensing lidar that are solid-state
embedded processors based on GPU like in
videos and a good performance but low
cost IMU and those are available these
days based on MEMS then you have three
of those core technologies you have
advanced systems that use these
technologies and those can be autonomous
driving system ADA or they support smart
home smart cities 3d aware device
devices we'll talk about all this and
ultimately smart solutions include that
the global map I talked about which is
centimeter accurate in 3d in color and
so on updated daily GPS free navigation
when you have a map that's that when you
have a high-definition map that's really
high quality high high accuracy now you
can navigate a bit offline you can
navigate offline you don't you don't
need a GPS to navigate the the whole
issue of urban canyons what happens when
you're in a tunnel and so on goes away
when you have onboard all the
information you need to navigate and
you're sensing constantly and locating
yourself and
smart IOT just is just such a broad
space and ultimately we learn will
change lives as we know them the we
address many markers let me jump ahead
show you the big bullet boring bullet
list it's gonna make you dizzy about
3,000 different applications we bucket
them into four pillars transportation
very broadly defined industrial
automation mapping terrestrial and an
aerial and security security is defined
as everything from smart home to smart
cities to smart borders and here are
some some of the some examples of
applications and I point your attention
to the fact that for instance in
vehicles you know that that's almost
obvious at this point because we talked
them so much about this is such a hot
space you probably have a good idea how
that's used but as you can imagine also
every drone company wants to work with
us you have the lightest weight lowest
power draw you know highest resolution
lowest cost sensor smaller size so
that's a no-brainer for the drones and
ultimately we're going to be able to fit
in a in a handheld device and clothing
so on when the whole device is on a
single chip which pre-packaging has
about this size when you package it you
know it's a few millimeters thick and
now you have high-end high-performance
type of lidar this is not like the
gaming lighter you can buy these days
for that that works that has only a
10-foot range it works only indoors when
there's no sunlight and it has low
accuracy if you walk around the house
and you come back to where you started
it looks like you're off by 10 feet and
so on that's all
this works outdoors has a 300 meter
range works in bright sunlight has high
resolution this is the kind of thing if
it's if you had this on a cell phone or
on any device you can go like this and
map big architectural structure you can
map whatever you want capture is seen or
just by waving this around so that's
that's that's the future everything we
do is by design based on silicon CMOS so
all the individual components that go
into making this particular multi chip
module based solid-state lidar when it
becomes a single ASIC can be integrated
on a single substrate because it's all
based on standard silicon CMOS and
that's why it's also a very low cost you
see the the business part of this D but
you see that this chip right here which
is about 4 by 4 millimeters you can be
you can calculate how many you can get
out of a 12 inch wafer and the yields
have been phenomenal we have not had a
chip that does not work because we have
you know we have a developed calibration
Hardware boards and calibration
algorithms that calibrate out
imperfections in fab so so far after we
do that we run the calibration so far
every chip has worked so that gives you
an idea how we we can hit the kind of
numbers we've been talking about this is
we sell this a couple hundred bucks in
volume and this is going to be below 100
potentially below $50 in volume but I
told you about where it does the grade
the range the the environmental
conditions that can deal with and so on
so I don't want to hear I can buy a
gaming lidar for 10 bucks you know this
is just this is just totally different
so the product you know the products we
build based on these technologies and
these capabilities they lead and cost
performance reliability size weight
power consumption let me clarify by
performance I mean I mean it
quickly range how long it is accuracy as
well as resolution so we do accuracy we
define as you know depth accuracy
resolution is lateral resolution
reliability we both mean lifetime how
long it takes before mean time between
failures is very high mean time between
failure for this is over a hundred
thousand hours of operation mechanical
light hours typically have mean time
between failure riddle 1000 hours of
operation some of them have 100 hours of
operation as well as lifetime is one
thing the other thing is the ability to
do signal processing and drop out false
signals identify for signals from from
from from false positives and false
negatives from real signals in rain snow
dust any any time our laser pulses hit
an aerosol any kind of solid in the air
they get broadened and when we see that
signature we know it's not a real return
one date a real object pedestrian
vehicles etc we don't we don't see that
effect so I'll show you some examples
that would actually an example that was
run live at the Nvidia booth at CES
where they had they had the train and
they had video and Lida and our lidar
and you see the difference so before so
that was the application part before we
get into the more technical part in any
any questions about what the product is
and technologies behind it we'll talk
later about how the technologies work
and you know what you know the appetite
of different markets so this is the part
where one discussed more markets and
applications and address any questions
you might have
you know minimum configuration has two
front right front left that's all you
mean and we are gonna embed video in
this library so just for color not for
perception some people who is video for
perception I just want to be able to see
the traffic light I want to be able to
read signs
and I want to colorize the the point
cloud to to just create data set that's
just more valuable to units this shows
the advantages of lidar vs. radar versus
video no one disagrees that lidar is the
most capable perception sensor some
people argue that it's an overkill when
it was very expensive before we we came
along people were arguing that it's an
overkill it's just it's too capable you
know you don't need something that's
that capable you can do okay with a
whole bunch about with the sweetest
answers including ultrasonic sensors
video cameras and radar a total of 24
sensors 12 ultrasonic sensors 6 radar 8
video cameras and you can get the job
done under most conditions on a highway
in good weather but now with with the
with with the introduction of this
ladder to the market you know you won't
he'd hear anyone say that lidar is not
needed
before they were justifying why they're
not using it's the cost yeah some cases
yeah the main case is fog in very thick
fog that's the weakest that's the
weakest link for using 5 nanometers to
stay in silicon CMOS that's why that's
why exactly I want to be able to detect
in the silicon-silicon stops detecting
at 1,100 nanometer I want to be below
that and I want to use lasers that are
already produced four different markets
at very low cost you know I want to buy
my laser chip for a couple of bucks you
could go to 1550 now you have to detect
in 3 5 compound semiconductors you know
in gas based detectors and you have you
know then and and you you can use a
higher power laser that's it
so the laser becomes expensive the the
attacker is expensive everything becomes
more expensive so well there's some
divergence so at the hot and we actually
have the capability I'll describe 7
unique capabilities we have because this
is solid-state and it does not have have
a physical configuration that it
determines the collimation it's all
software controlled what I can give you
is the minimum spot size you can make it
as big as you want the minimum spot size
at 100 meters is three point five
centimeters typical mechanical lidar
such as the one on the Google car at a
hundred meter it has a spot size of 2
meters and now we have one and a half
inch with this but you can make it as
big as you want if you want what we'll
talk about all the this unique
capability so we always recommend having
to lie dollars front right front left
and to radar forward looking forward and
looking back and that's a complete
system in terms of the sensing suite 66
gigahertz yeah
our bounder is our closest radar partner
and Tier one partner in general is
Delphi and so we use their their radar
yes so this shows now we're physically
in installation you know the Google card
that you all know and love with with the
scaffolding on top that holds the they
go the the bulky heavy unit so on which
is fine for R&D and this vehicle was a
gift to us from our partner Mercedes
Benz and we demonstrated that live at at
CES in two months Awad in in January the
this black fascia was actually designed
for us by Delphi it's I are transparent
basic it's basically the same material
that you make this Cobra auto IR has
more than 95% transmission through this
so you don't see the lidar and that's
the beauty you just see some some shiny
black fascia it looks beautiful and it's
something that people would buy it looks
a stunning and you don't see any
contraption on the outside and they're
basically for a total of a thousand one
thousand dollars you can have a full
autonomous vehicle system you can make a
vehicle autonomous with the system that
has to lie doors to raid our accessories
software Plus margin 1000 people used to
think that would day if you look at some
reports written by the robot robotics
office of the US Army and so on three
years ago they used to say - it takes
about two hundred thousand dollars to
make a truck autonomous now we're down
to 1,000
this is a road map so I have to say the
first lidar we made is also mechanical
because it's easy we were able to get
the market quickly and we still had the
smallest size lightest weight lowest
cost highest performance highest
reliability and you know lowest power
consumption compared to any other
mechanical lidar but still it wasn't
mechanical it was not solid a solid
state has all these advantages to
greater extent and it is completely
solid state ultimately everything will
be on one chip you embed that in a cell
phone and your clothing in your hat I
mean when you think of the applications
I mean this can make blind people see
you can send a chirp or audio or some
kind of even a brain signal that lost a
blind person to see applications are
almost limitless 100 you must have
looked into that oh you see the the
pricing here well I say it again people
yeah
and as I point out here the video
cameras will be integrated in this just
for color everything we do everything
we're doing now and we'll do in the
future would be all solid-state our
first vehicle which is all which was
also a gift from mercedes-benz we
mounted our mechanical ladders on not
they're smaller they're about this big
the size of a small coffee mug you know
but still it was sitting on the outside
on some on the baggage rack and so on
it's not as easy to integrate that into
a into the body of the vehicle but
that's just the gen one which which is
not for automotive applications that
that's still fine for for security
application static applications the
prime of the vehicle you hit potholes
there is vibrations it's not an
environment for a mechanical solution we
if it's a static installation security
installation and static in the
installation mechanical lidar might be
okay it gives you a 360 view this one as
you can imagine well theoretically the
most you can get out of the face of a
chip is 180 degrees right you're not
going to send south the sunlight out the
back of the ship right so we actually
use the central 120 degrees to get the
sweet spot of scanning if you go too far
to the edge the range gets gets yeah you
know the amplitude of the signal gets
the decreases and the range decreases so
this is hundred million degrees in
mechanical 360 if you have if a silicon
on a pole and doing monitoring for Road
intersection railroad intersection
monitoring some kind of safe site
industrial facility and oil and gas
field whatever it might be a border I
mean this is you know I mean instead of
building a big concrete wall you know
Trump should consider you
exactly I know I can see your faces they
don't let me side either but you know
all kidding aside you know the you could
have one of these every 500 meters or so
and it's a smart smart because it's
gonna see as soon as someone starts to
approach and you dispatch secure
security cam is sitting in an
air-conditioned office and you
dispatched someone when there's a known
event as opposed to patrolling the
us-mexico border or whichever border
right it's its tracks it detects tracks
and it's very persistent meaning our
software is so smart that once it knows
that there was something here and if
someone hides behind the bush it's gonna
remember that sucker just just hid
behind the bush and I'm gonna wait till
he appears again it's not that you know
you cannot it's very very persistent we
have you know a file they should start
issuing soon the company is three and a
half years old we start to file patents
about one year into the company and they
would go over the next year they should
start the issue we have about 15 more in
preparation you've seen this you know if
you see the real thing here so you don't
need to spend time on this it's nine by
six by six centimeters so the principle
of operation it's an optical phased
array an optical phased array you can
take pictures if you want we're going to
give you the slides as well yeah the
basically the the business part is this
this chip here so it's a a chip up about
the this I don't know if you can see
from from afar but the chip that the
business part is this piece of silicon
that's about four by four millimeters
this is one array that that scans in the
2d space this is this has a 120 by 120
degree field of view
this is of course a cartoon that the
actual circuit is a lot more complex
when you add the different the the
there's the photonic circuit there is
the the interconnect layer to bring the
control signals there's the actuation
elements and the out-of-plane coupling
that sends the light from being guided
inside the chip to comment out to come
on basically normally to the chip and
now those beams were by controlling
their faces we can get them to create a
spot size of any size pointed in any
direction within the entire field of
view that gets calibrated once in the
factory and it's good for the lifetime
some unique capabilities that no other
lidar has only because this is
solid-state you can adjust the the
window of of interest within the field
of view so if this is if you if the unit
gives you 120 by 120 degrees you might
say I'm interested for this application
in 120 by making 10 degrees if it's a
vehicle looking mostly at the horizon
and so on if it's a big mining vehicle
that's a three-story tall and it's
looking at you know people walking down
and it's trying to not you know flick
the dump truck that's trying to fill and
so on they would probably use the full
120 by 120 depends on the application
and smart home applications you also
want to see everything that's going on
around you for security application yeah
you're using yeah controller so is like
the YouTube go mining company the firm
you guys are using with your birth
movers and stuff like that with your
wire in the mining company was the
company that was using your light ours
on the earth universe no let me think if
any mining company I'll show you some
customers that whose names are public
I'm not gonna disclose any
customer names where we don't have the
their approval to the none of the mining
companies give us the okay to disclose
their name I can tell you our top two
mining companies one is American one is
Japanese distribution of points when you
when you collect a point cloud in a
mechanical system everything is set so
it has multiple layers that are spinning
or scanning or oscillating distance
between them is set you know the you
know the resolution of data collection
is set here you can change the point
distribution based on the application
you can you can see I want a higher
point density around along the horizon
where I'm looking at the what's going on
on the road trying to detect every
little thing you know little baby small
animal the pothole someone so that can
debris that fell off a truck or
something but when I'm looking up and
down when I'm looking down I just want
to see the lane markings when I'm
looking up I mainly want to see bridges
signs or if there's a road in front of
you that that has an upslope you want to
actually detect the the vehicles on it
before you you climb up that slope
random access you can do completely
random access with with it with the
system it takes the same amount of time
to go from any direction and it with any
spot size to any other direction with
any other spot size so that has
advantages based on the scene you're
looking at also in terms of
signal-to-noise ratio because when on
the on the receiver side if the spot you
just hit you did not just hit before
that the the adjacent spot you don't
have electron leakage and that helps you
with signal-to-noise ratio so you can
jump around have been algorithms optimal
configuration for for the sequence in
which you you jump around yeah we have
zoom in zoom out capability which is
unheard of in the world of lidar that
that's equivalent to
mechanical lighter I'm gonna take my
glass lens or plastic lens and actually
deform at every microsecond you know
change its shape and it's probably
impossible as you know they know a lens
let's say a glass lens based on its
thickness
you know delay is light by by by by you
know by by you know the the factor that
has to do with the refractive index so
you are so so you know if there's not
nothing you can do about changing the
property of the lensing assembly here we
can change the phase value can slow down
the light with a signal which would be
equivalent to changing at every 80
million points on a lens it's equivalent
to changing the thickness of the glass
so that gives you the ability to do zoom
and zoom out we can change the frame
rate you have each sensor has collects
half a million points per second one
every two microseconds so you can
distribute those anywhere you want
across however many frames you want you
can have a thousand frames per second
each one having 500 points or you can
have one frame per second having half a
million points or anything in between we
can also enhance the range to the size
of the extent of looking forward when it
when you know you have a pre-existing
map you know that you got an
intersection and you can actually look
further out towards the side at the
expense of looking forward which is okay
when you're at the stop sign you don't
have to see more than 50 meters ahead of
you and you're a stop sign but you would
really like to see 150 200 meters to the
side all all these seven capabilities
are not supported by any other lighter
that exists you know any lighter who do
it goes through the full battery of
tests you have to go through to be
qualified to be automotive grade this is
what we did on the on the mechanical
lidar you typical temperature wide
temperature range vibration
shark ensuring its eye safe under all
operating conditions a lifetime UV
exposure in direct sunlight for the
entire lifetime and so on that's the our
first vehicle you get with with the kind
of data that you see in it as you
driving around in real time you see the
different layers from each lidar one of
our customers were in oh you know the
sister company of Nissan basically we
have used four of our lied ours this
this was the mechanical lighter the
appointment in four corners and they
drove around basically it it turned the
vehicle to in turn autonomous vehicle
they did some highway driving cone
detection driving they were up and
running very quickly because they took
not only our hardware but also our
software our perception software and
they they were able to collect nice
videos any snapshot I have of a video I
actually also have the full video on
this laptop so if we have time at the
end if you're interested I have tons of
videos let me just keep track of time oh
this question the minimum range for the
mechanical lidar which is the one used
here is one meter the minimum range for
the solid state ladder is 10 centimeters
so if it's mounted let's say in a behind
the grill or you know in the Bob and a
bumper let's say the way it we martyred
and the in the red SUV it was behind the
grill basically if you stand right
against it and your legs are touching
the bumper you're more than 10
centimeters away from the sensor
so in terms of time we have to find 545
so this is beaming to where oh is it
so streaming live to folks who sign up
for the real truth two more days to that
it's March 30 yesterday hey that's you
know as you know advanced driver a
system we can support all the ADA's
functions and you can see them here
lane-keeping Park Assist and so on did
you say bus can you do pass retention
yeah so you know in all Paris to Google
this was a the algorithm was programmed
to to assume that if you pull in front
of a bus and it's doing less than 20
miles per hour almost like it's gonna
slow down they have not seen how bus
drivers drive in the Bay Area
you know the ADA system that typically
had some long range narrow field of view
short range wide field-of-view radar and
some video cameras might have like this
might have a configuration like this
everything is a scholar can be in color
can be seen the hashed area is are the
blind spots so you don't have full
coverage of the blind spots he certainly
not have any visibility for what's
coming at you from at an intersection
from sides side streets with to light
dollars you got this kind of coverage
all around
oh how are you getting straight online
when you put the lighthouse on the roof
oh yeah yeah because the sensors or not
you can't put it behind metal right
right it's line of sight it does not go
through metal right so in this case you
know because it's with the passenger
vehicle you have to worry a lot about
the aesthetics they are dynamic but a
big hunk a truck you don't care very
truck yeah right so if you stick them on
the roof you can when you get beyond the
shadow in the effect you start to see
the back will you be getting into the
actual technology of what makes these
things work yeah yeah you know I'm
covering the the hardware I showed what
the chip looks like and how it works and
so on and we'll get into we still have
25 minutes yes this is the configuration
so very quickly I mentioned previously
what a typical configuration made out of
eight cameras six radar twelve
ultrasonic sensors if you add the
mechanical lidar because you cannot it's
you cannot use it to support a safety
critical function by itself and you you
only add it on top of the existing suite
if it's a solid state ladder and you can
count on it running reliably you drop
most of the other sensors you keep two
radars so a system that's basically the
kind of autopilot system you hear about
these days that it works on the highway
on a sunny day
if there is no shading from a tree on
the highway and so on it costs about
four thousand total you had a couple of
light hours if it's our mechanical lidar
yeah two thousand others other
mechanical ladders you had two times
eight 16 seconds 20 and the solid state
ladder plus 2 right radar is a thousand
bucks how many
tonight as which indeed over dollars how
much with the two that says to me about
their four thousand gave you yeah we our
goal is to get to ten nines we we can I
know it's it's a very challenging we we
can get eight nines and we just it's we
have to keep pushing the technology how
many false positives so with very nice
that's one out of you know so eight nine
says false positive versus a false
negative
it's really depends on the scenario use
a knows it's a when you start all right
so it's it could be false positive or
false negative it's you know it's one
out of about one out of about one about
in one in ten million situations so you
might miss one out of ten million things
that you should have picked up yeah
software before it's a system answer
yeah
All Things Considered so with the
software we're going to keep improving
things to get to the closer to the ten
nines that's gonna be all software grow
because the sensor is what it is and
it's a matter of interpretation and
making the artificial intelligence
smarter and smarter
with deep learning we have our systems
on the garbage trucks of the city of
Sunnyvale basically and they they detect
sometimes you know garbage truck is
backing up out of an alley and they
don't see well what's coming at them and
they got into accidents and so on
yeah I can give you lots of scenarios we
can do object detection tracking
classification color coding for each
object you track it and
you do scenario analysis and then you
decide on an action action plan based on
the scenario actual the truck stops you
know of the city of Sunnyvale it's with
specialty solid waste and recycling we
have you see there's one lidar here and
one lidar here city of San Jose is
mapping a corridor for us so we launched
the solid state light are at CES this is
the after Michael Haffner who was the
senior VP of products at Daimler Co
announcing with me on stage at sea as
the the solid state lidar
so this is what this was a big deal for
us because this is what we are all about
this is the what allows us this is the
entry point and to this all these
applications then we make the solution
robust and powerful through software but
this is the enabling technology right
here that I showed you this vehicle that
they gave us it was running live at the
CES basically when you when you look at
either person you know you could you see
the the contour of their bodies you know
a live image a video would would look
nicer because as they move around you
can see how the shape changes this is
the demo done with our lidar a video in
front of a rain curtain that were the
that was getting heavier sometimes at
the the Nvidia booth at CES and you can
read for yourself what Brad Templeton
who's the pharmaceutical expert wrote
just based on him standing there and
watching the demonstration basically
when the when the rain got heavy and the
vision failed the lidar kept detecting
we can see through rain the laser is
what's that you can count the raindrops
while you're driving through if a a an
area that has lots of trees you can
actually count the leaves if you want
the information is there just that
you you just have to ask for it how does
the sensor work we send a so let's focus
on the solid state sensor because it
works differently from the mechanical
the mechanical lighter is much easier oh
they're they're both our products okay
we also make mechanical items yeah
that's okay the mechanical sends one
pulse detects it with an APD measured
time-of-flight it's a time flight
measurement this is also time of flight
but this is different this is now here
the detector operation and geiger mode
so the digital mode which is basically
photon counting mode so that that's what
company is called the quality we we
count quanta of optical energy well you
know we are close the part on the well
you know we once you can't once you you
do that a photon there's what's called
at that time we try to make that as
small as possible to be able to count
the next photon we we send the photon
pulses that are coded so that was that's
a pulse train typically about 10 pulses
per shot that's coated so when the
signal comes back we have we have a
match filter that detects the signal out
of the noise when you look at the signal
coming back it looks like all noise but
when you run the match filter it picks
out the signal based on the code
pseudo-random that's exactly right as as
GPS does these days you know so that's
the process all strain coded and
detection and we do a spatial temporal
correlation to ensure that we are
detecting a signal that's the a a real
signal or not a false signal so
we have a spider a single photon
Avalanche diode array on the receiver
side behind it there's an ROIC readout
integrated circuit together they make a
receiver detector and ROIC make a
receiver array so we you know we do the
detection with the single photon
counting with the with with this pad
array now despite any any spider array
has an active area and a area that has
the circuitry so do you have a fill
factor for the active region we have a
good fill factors often the fill factor
is about five percent we have 25 percent
fill factor but still you don't want a
signal to come back at you and hit a
dead area that does not have an active
zone so by design we defocus the signal
that comes back so it hits at least a
couple of pixels in each dimension and
that that's now a special correlation
you want multiple adjacent detector
pixels to pick up the signal for you to
say that I have a real signal so we have
the code we have the spatial correlation
then we have the temporal correlation
each one as opposed to zero in the panda
in the pulse train has to give the same
information on the range and when all
the pulses in the pot-stirring give you
the same information you have now you
have temporal correlation the
time-of-flight measure is the same for
all of them when you combine all these
three measures you have rock-solid
detection even in a high noise level
environment this is the kind of map we
can collect by driving once this is our
office building here in Sunnyvale just
by driving once around the block you get
this kind of dense point cloud we can
zoom in this is this one of the turns
here and you look at well once you
collect the wants to collect this is a
point cloud
you know na what's called the back file
it becomes an environment that you can
actually do a fly through on your
computer and it's you canyou can
actually fly through just like in a
video game and take a still like this
from from any perspective so this we're
we're doing a fly through close to the
ground it shows you a high level of
detail the you can see the curvature of
the road the curbs the lane markings
now the lane markings keep in mind I'm
only showing you now height that let me
take you to this you can do color coding
based on intensity in this case the lane
markings the right turn signal the stop
signs are they really stand out they
really jump out at you but even when you
look at just the height the resolution
is so high that the thickness of the
paint is picked up just based on height
you can see where the lane markings are
and you can leave really traffic signs
that's where you can read graphic signs
based on any difference in reflectivity
between the lettering and the background
but you can also lose it just with video
just just use the three dollar cellphone
camera but this is a situation where we
said you know you can actually you can't
count the the leaves on a tree without
many applications we pre map a course
this is WRC rally race course that we
pre mapped for Hyundai so they can take
very detailed notes before they do the
race it's not allowed to do it during
the race but it's perfectly fine to do
it before the racing and then then take
detailed notes and now use your
handwritten notes for for more accurate
information we can do global positioning
of point clouds we can overlay our point
clouds on top of satellite imagery and
you can see any changes day to day in
in the scenery and you can position
yourself and you can detect the changes
yes
representations of how your software
interprets the data I still don't
understand how the sensor itself works
what are the phenomena that you're using
in order to collect the data that you're
showing us we are connecting we have we
have a time flight of sensor we have an
IMU right inertial measurement unit
which is accelerometer and and pixels
what are the dimensions of the sensor or
how is it that you're determining the
time of flight
what is the emitter I don't know if
these are lasers being put out but they
seem to be blasting world energy okay so
you're referring to when you blast the
world with energy it's it's called the
flashlight our approach we don't do that
we do we have much smaller we do serial
illumination as opposed to parallel
illumination the flashlights are does
luminous the entire scene with one big
spot they flash the entire scene that
means the power has to be very high they
use laser it's on the order of 100
kilowatt and power very expensive to
make that I say if you go to 1550 cannot
detect in silicon anymore you go to
gallium arsenide hundred times more
expensive that's why those systems cost
between 100 and 200 thousand dollars
Syria Syria I have a small spot that
hops around a million times per second
that's what I do they flash the entire
scene so if you a million times per
second it your failure is 1 out of 10
million that's fine it's fine because
you're collecting so much information
that and you're putting it all together
and it has to make sense if especially
the one false signal that does that does
not repeat because it was some random
noise then you know you know what you're
dealing with a you got eventually very
quickly I realized that that was a false
return
you're running at thirty fifty hundred
thousand frames per second and if one of
these frames has one dot that's one
point cloud point that's erroneous
you'll figure that out very quickly
within a small fraction of a second a
billion billion yep chose 10 billion in
the United States I don't know what they
do in England closest partner for the
for the invest processor is in video we
use their Tegra x1 platform for for deep
learning it has to be much cheaper for
this to go into in every vehicle but for
vehicles that collect their to do deep
learning and build a strengthen the
algorithm based on driving around
learning teaching teaching the algorithm
correcting it in post-processing and so
on you know that's a very powerful
platform very powerful platform I'm
gonna be focusing on that topic at GTCC
next week so when we collect a point
cloud data you know the PCL steps
basically involve point cloud collection
there is a you snap all the frames to
the same coordinate system based on the
IMU information so you have a point
cloud that's basically clean where
everything is in the same coordinate
system you apply some filtering you know
Kalman filtering you do segmentation
beyond that you do surface
reconstruction based on the segments
that you identified after you've done
clustering
and then we do object classification you
can do it beyond that model fitting and
and more realistic look give it a more
realistic look based on the model
fitting we have data coming in from the
lidar from the IMU and vehicle data on
on the speed steering angle direction of
tires they did vehicle has lots of
information and each OM decides you know
how much to give you we have our big
wish list of what you would like to have
to have the most robust set of inputs
into our perception software and auto
death comes in an object list not now
you basically you you have positioned
yourself you it's it's you know you have
determined where the ground plane is
where the objects are what each object
is is doing and you put out a constantly
refreshed object list typically most OEM
just take that list from you and they
take it from there
yeah just Tom 10 to a hundred times per
second what you're saying where
everything is that's all they need and
from frame to frame did you track the
so five to thirty Hertz PCL point cloud
is what automakers ask for we can go
100,000 Hertz but that's you know that's
the strong capability that's beyond what
they asked for it's just it's it's a
bonus that they get in terms of the
format's PCL or Ross today and ATT F and
in the future we do have this feedback
process where we our sensors collect
data that gets processed and our light
our software now puts out a map and that
basically it collects the Delta between
the map you saw on the map that exists
feeds that to the cloud to update the
cloud and the map then that in the cloud
now everybody else is feeding their data
and you the day and you got assisted
with map assist based on everyone's data
to refer to refresh your own base map
and that allows us to keep our Maps
up-to-date on both the base map on and
remo supported the base map and then
what what you detectable will actually
allow you to detect objects on top of
the base map so we have this ability to
do real-time 3d mapping which allows us
to communicate Road and weather quality
conditions allows us to communicate
traffic observations flow conditions of
the traffic objects accident obstacle
debris in in real-time with centimeter
accuracy we have Lane level we built
lien Douglas Street Maps
the infrastructure is mapped all with
centimeter accuracy we have you know a
full array of location-based services
that's included in this capability
through the distance but there's also an
X Y you're trying to scan thousands of
pixels for megapixels in order to get a
decent image instead of isolated points
yeah
however you believe you get back at each
point and at what angular dispersion at
30 meters 30 meters you get one
centimeter accuracy in all in all the
dimensions in depth in X and in Y and
all of that becomes about three
centimeters at 100 meter frame and the
frame rate is software controlled by the
algorithm based on the scenario it's ten
to a hundred times per second you got a
higher pulse repetition frequency all
right like that the pulse repetition
itself is constant and how many pulses
we have per shot is constant but how
many shots we use to collect each data
point that we the algorithm decides on
the fly any object that's nearby and
reflective and so on one shot if you
want to see something very far you got a
weak return from something that's very
far and you want to collect more
information and identify its shape and
its nature and so on you can actually
send multiple shots and accumulate and
fill your bins out the business of your
histogram and using what's called DC SBC
time correlated single photon sensing a
little bit that you wanna consumer be
able to drive that's fine vehicle moving
at 200 kilometers per hour is almost
like card out of bounds field that's
right it's
it's basically standing still for a for
compared to comparing this video well
what is the local storage of memory
taking into account and temporal filters
that can be fairly deep yeah so are you
asking about the platform we use for the
storage are you asking about is
available for yeah there's a there's
there's local buffering inside the
sensor and then we have in the vehicle
but outside the sensor we have your
terabyte solid-state drive are you
asking about the type of storage we use
yeah so we have both storage on chip and
then we have the post processing then we
we have the data post in vehicle
processing we have everything stored on
on a solid-state drive it's good for
five days if you drop eight hours in a
day collecting at the highest resolution
yeah so you know just so this is
actually my last slide to give you an
idea some customers I can talk about the
diameter group Mercedes red liner
Hyundai Kia Renault Nissan oh yeah for
OEM are top tier one partner for system
on the system level Delphi on the
component level which is called a Tier
two its sensor technologies which is the
former sensor division of Ti so the
timing is good because that's it I'm
done we have seven offices globally so
and we are hiring lots of software
people so thank you for your time
you